nous sommes sur la terre de Fred
Pellerin nous sommes donc chez lui mais
une partie de son terrain a été climée
c'est à dire qu'une compagnie ou une
personne a acheté un titre minier pour
potentiellement et faire de
l'exploration minière tu es un peu plus
chez vous parce que le propriétaire qui
est en-dessus comme un droit d'accès par
chez vous pour aller en dessous de chez
vous comme bien d'autres citoyens de la
région inquiets il a décidé d'acheter
des titres miniers pour protéger son
territoire mais il y avait une partie de
ma forêt qui était pas climée enfin que
là en voyant tout ça c'est la loi des
mines c'est un peu stigidou
le premier qui est arrivé c'est à lui
puis le premier qui a acheté ce Bootle
reste à lui
fac c'était un peu encore un bail que
c'est géré puis là ben j'appelais comme
disait me sécuriser pas par rapport à
possibilité d'éventuellement voir des
forages de la prospection se faire chez
nous le conseiller municipal le pôle
intention de laisser trouer ce beau
paysage là en 2011 les citoyens de
satellite klaxon avaient réussi en se
mobilisant à faire fuir une minière qui
convoitait du cuivre Gilbert Guérin
était à la tête de cette mobilisation
citoyenne il est prêt à accompagner la
municipalité dans cette nouvelle
bataille actuellement 49 titres actifs
couvrent le territoire de la
municipalité on va mettre à jour notre
coffre d'outils
parce que la loi a changé en 2013 en
attendant que la loi soit dépoussiée ce
qu'il recommande c'est d'acheter des
titres miniers
je pense que c'est en train de regarder
mais là comme citoyen nous ça veut dire
que la seule option qu'on a c'est de se
créer ça reste une solution temporaire
parce que le Clen tu l'achètes pour
trois ans après ça il faut investir dans
la prospection dans le développement
minier si je pense pas au moins comme
citoyen je peux mettre à faire du forage
puis ça reste une solution temporaire si
on prétend depuis longtemps vouloir
faire avancer la loi des mines en haut
chez nos dirigeants en consultation
ancien en soi date n'est pas grand chose
qui apparaît qui semble bouger comme
tout le monde minière ou citoyens Fred
Pellerin a acheté ses titres miniers sur
le site j’estime du gouvernement du
Québec les siens apparaissent en
turquoise parce qu'il les a acquis
récemment
que il y a une vague de turquoise qui
envahissent le territoire de tous ces
clims
correspond à des gestes citoyens à du
monde qui ont aucun intérêt dans le
forage puis la prospection minière mais
qu'ils font pour protéger le territoire
je pense que ça parlerait aussi dans le
geste ici Julie Grenon Radio-Canada
Sainte-Hélène kaxton